[Music]
so we took mushrooms together once Oh
God
that's we didn't just take mushrooms we
planned a mushroom trip we were at a
coffee shop and we said hey I wonder if
we could rent a place in Big Bear and we
did and then I wonder
we have mushrooms we got ahold of
mushrooms and we got into our place and
I basically walk in my room I've got my
dog I drop all my stuff off I come out
and you're on the wooden chalkboard
you've chopped the mushrooms up and
you've started mixing them with peanut
butter and Nutella Nutella cuz I'm not
around I think one of the best moments
was the Blues for the zoo remember that
the Blues we were on the water on our
cabin and across the bay from where we
were was apart and there was a blues
concert happening yeah middle of the day
as a benefit show for the zoo can I back
you up a little bit yes cuz we're all
having this bad trip okay it's not a
good time it wasn't hit me too bad I'm
having a bathroom I remember your dog
Mike he had like stepped on a thorn or
some [__]
oh yeah you're like Oh Mikey Mikey and I
stood up and when you're worried about
the dog I'm stuck in a psychological
prison they yelled to you and then I
said this is one of the proudest moments
of my life because I'm having this bad
thing the walls are melting all the
cliches and we're just like stuck to the
couch not a good time and then I decided
my ego that what was remaining of my ego
said that's like a real Harrison Ford
get off me a moment I stood up and I
said we're not doing this we're having a
visual times dance this will not stand
this is just Sparta and that blues band
that sounded like the devil himself
jamming earlier yes suddenly sounded
awesome and telling all the people would
happen because we didn't get a boat no
no we and it was October necessarily
swimming time yeah we got in the water
and swam to the blues concert felt so
with swimming nobody would be swinging
out of the water like creatures from
another world imagine here your mid 40s
50s you love Jimmy Buffett and light
jazz blues and you're drinking the beer
you brought them home and a cooler and
me and you emerge from the water it's
not a swimming time we're just now I'm
standing in our bathing suits we didn't
lose you all around us and we went to a
place to buy martinis we didn't like sir
you need a wallet there's tickets and
we're like we don't have things we can't
and then security comes over like you
guys gotta leave more like I will just
walk out the front like no people
worried bout like watching the concert
from the water and we're just swimming
by from whence we came evolutionarily
and also that afternoon
[Music]